AND JIMMY JOE JURKIC DIDN'T FOUL
NOBODY.
>> THAT IS THE BEST I'VE EVER
HEARD.
>> THAT'S REALLY GOOD.
>> WE THOUGHT, HOW DO YOU TAKE
THAT TO THE NEXT LEVEL?
HERE'S HOW.
YOU HAVE CHARLES BARKLEY
INTERVIEW CHARLES BARKLEY.
DANNY JOINS US FROM WASHINGTON,
D.C.
I'VE BEEN LOOKING FORWARD TO
CHUCK INTERVIEWING CHUCK.
>> IT'S A GREAT, FIRST OF ALL,
IT'S A PLEASURE TO HAVE ME HERE.
IT'S AN HONOR.
LIKE I SAY, I'VE BEEN DOING THIS
FOR MANY YEARS, AND I'VE BEEN
DOING THIS AND IT'S GOOD TO BE
APPRECIATED.
BEFORE WE CAME ON THE AIR, WE
DIDN'T GET AS MANY AWARDS AS WE
SHOULD HAVE.
BACK TO YOU, ERNIE.
>> WHAT DO YOU GOT FOR THE
CHUCKSTER.
>> CHUCK, THIS IS CHUCK.
I WANTED TO ASK YOU, LIKE I SAY,
HOW COME WHEN IT'S YOUR TURN TO
TALK, WHY DO YOU BRACE YOURSELF
LIKE IT'S AN EARTHQUAKE WITH
YOUR RIGHT HAND?
>> YOU HAVE TO SPEAK WITH POWER.
YOU HAVE TO SPEAK WITH
CONVICTION.
LET PEOPLE KNOW YOU'RE IN THE
ROOM.
YOU PUT YOUR HAND DOWN TO GET
THEIR ATTENTION FIRST AND
FOREMOST.
>> THAT DIDN'T MAKE NO SENSE.
HERE'S MY NEXT QUESTION FOR
CHUCK, THIS IS ALSO CHUCK.
WHEN IT'S KENNY'S CHANCE TO
TALK, AND YOU THROW HIM THE
PRETEND BALL, WHY DOES KENNY
HAVE A PAINED EXPRESSION ON HIS
FACE WHEN IT'S HIS TIME.
>> I CAN ANSWER THAT.
>> GO AHEAD, JET.
>> BACK TO YOU.
>> HEY, CHUCK, EVERY TIME YOU
ASK ME A QUESTION, CHUCK, I HAVE
TO HEAR IT LIKE FIRST OF ALL,
AND IT'S NOT REALLY FIRST OF
ALL.
IT'S USUALLY SECOND OF ALL,
THIRD, FOURTH, OR FIFTH OF ALL.
HE'S ALWAYS USING THE SAME ONE
AS IF IT'S THE FIRST TIME WE'RE
HEARING IT AND IT'S NOT.
>> CHUCK, THAT MADE SENSE.
SEE HOW THAT ANSWERS MADE SENSE?
>> HERE IT IS --
>> FIRST OF ALL, THERE IT IS.
FIRST OF ALL.
>> STAY IN CHARACTER, DANNY.
STAY IN CHARACTER.
>> FIRST OF ALL, GO AHEAD.
FIRST OF ALL WHAT?
>> YOU MAKE SENSE, ERNIE MAKES
SENSE, AND YOU MAKE SENSE.
>> WHAT ABOUT SHAQ?
>> HE DON'T MAKE SENSE.
>> I DON'T NEED TO, I MAKE
DOLLARS AND CENTS.
>> GO AHEAD, CHUCK.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH, ERNIE.
THIS IS CHUCK AGAIN FOR CHUCK.
MY QUESTION IS, HOW COME EVERY
TIME THERE'S A HIGHLIGHT, AND
THERE'S A CENTER IN THE ARENA,
HOW COME CHUCK TAKES CREDIT FOR
THE CENTER?
>> THANK YOU, DANNY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HE CAN'T GIVE NO BIG MAN NO
CREDIT.
>> BECAUSE I'M THE REIGNING KING
OF BIG MEN.
IF YOU DON'T LIKE IT, COME DOWN
AND SAY SOMETHING ABOUT IT.
I'LL COME TO WASHINGTON, D.C.,
AND GET SOME FURNITURE MOVING
DOWN THERE.
>> SHAQ WAS ON TWITTER TODAY, HE
SAID TO ME, ANY PUNK CAN DO
CHARLES BARKLEY.
I THINK THAT'S TRUE.
BUT HE SAID ANYBODY CAN DO
CHARLES, BUT CAN PEOPLE DO SHAQ?
I WOULD LIKE TO DO A JOKE
BETWEEN CHARLES AND SHAQ.
>> OH, YES.
>> SO, KNOCK, KNOCK, CHUCK.
LET ME ASK YOU SOMETHING.
>> I DON'T WANT TO HAVE A KNOCK,
KNOCK JOKE.
>> WHO IS THERE?
>> A SECOND TRIP TO THE FINALS.
>> NEVER MIND.
SEE WHAT I DID THERE?
>> THAT WAS GOOD.
>> THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, SHAQ.
CHUCK, I HAVE OTHER QUESTIONS,
IT'S BASICALLY ABOUT YOUR
GUARANTEES.
IS IT IMPORTANT TO EVER GET A
GUARANTEE RIGHT?
>> NO.
NO, JUST TO -- GUARANTEE!
♪♪
>> THAT'S GOING TO BLOW UP ONE
DAY, ERNIE.
>> MAN.
>> OKAY, OKAY.
TURN IT OFF!
ABORT, ABORT!
>> DANNY, YOU SEE WHAT YOU
STARTED THERE?
>> YOU CAN'T HATE.
THAT'S THE RIGHT ANSWER.
MY QUESTION IS, IF BOGDANOVIC
AND BOGDANOVIC FOUGHT FOR
BOGDANOVIC SUPREMACY, WHO WOULD
WIN?
>> THE BIG BOGDANOVIC.
>> WHICH ONE IS THAT?
>> YOU SAID BOBAN, RIGHT?
>> NO.
>> BOGDAN AND BOBAN.
THE UTAH BOGDANOVIC OR THE
ATLANTA BOGDANOVIC?
>> I'M GOING WITH THE ATLANTA
BOGDANOVIC.
>> THAT'S ALSO CORRECT.
>> DANNY, THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> CAN WE HEAR YOUR REGULAR
VOICE?
>> I FORGET HOW TO DO MY REGULAR
VOICE.
I'VE BEEN DOING THIS FOR A WHOLE
BUNCH OF DAYS.
THIS IS A PLEASURE.
YOU GUYS ARE THE BEST SHOW EVER.
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME.
>> CONTINUED SUCCESS.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THAT WAS FUN.
>> YOU KNOW WHO ELSE WORKS WITH
HIM?
YOU KNOW CHRIS MILES?
>> FROM NBA TV.
>> WHO WAS FUNNIER, HIM OR THE
GERMAN DUDE?
>> THEY'RE PRETTY CLOSE.
BUT IN TERMS OF A CH